what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar and today is a very special day
because I'm doing a video on you at Ichi
the strongest demon seer ever and one of
my favorite characters in anime you guys
voted for him via our Instagram story at
anime uproar and I'm glad you did as
usual if we can get 5,000 likes on this
video I will start on the next how
strong is video ASAP this is the
eleventh video on how strong are the
Demon Slayer characters and that's just
awesome if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell because you will miss
new videos if you don't you can now
listen to all of our videos as podcasts
on Spotify and iTunes just search up
anime upper audio or check out the links
in the description we drop the podcast
versions there before the video even
comes out on YouTube so you can count on
getting early access there in fact a
demon slayer chapter 189 review won't
come out on this channel until after the
official release comes out but if you
just can't wait i've already uploaded
the audio version as a podcast so you
can download it and check it out
whenever you want on Spotify or iTunes
just check the link in the description
as always there will be manga spoilers
in this video I need to look at all of
the relevant evidence to determine
exactly how strong your ichi is after
all now without further ado let's jump
into it even though your ichi was long
gone by the time the series started he
continues to have a huge influence on
the entire story and on present events
he actually got more attention than many
living characters the big bad villain of
the series moves on was almost killed by
him but then he realized how fast he was
and ran away like a coward yo Deecee
also taught other demon Slayers to use
breathing techniques to defeat demons
before him they were practically useless
against demons and if not for you Ichi
most of our current demon Slayers
wouldn't know how to use breathing
techniques and would be much weaker as a
result he is considered to be the most
talented and strongest Demon Slayer of
all time and ton zero our protagonist
seems to be the successor of his breath
of the Sun style now I will go over his
impressive accomplishments from birth to
his death so we can see exactly how
strong and special this man was you know
how tensional developed a demon ser mark
and then everyone else started to
develop them
well you and Ichi didn't even need to
develop a demon slayer mark he
was born with it it almost got him
killed because his father found it
disturbing yo Deecee was the younger
twin brother of Michi katsu
Sookie Cooney the man who would go on to
become upper Moon Wan kakushi bow even
though your Ichi would go on to become
so strong people thought he was inferior
to his older brother in the beginning
they could not see his potential at all
your Ichi was actually going to be
killed as a baby but his mother saved
him she convinced his father to send him
to a temple when he reached the age of
10 instead of killing him however even
though his life was saved he was treated
much worse than Michi katsu he got a
worse room worst clothes worst education
and worse food people thought he was
always clinging to his mother because he
was such a pitiable baby but at such a
young age he was actually helping to
support his mother who was sick unlike
vici katsu who got special treatment you
had Ichi got to grow up quickly
his older twin was not allowed to give
URI his things it was forbidden by their
father however he did care about his
brother so he made him a flute that your
Ichi would go on to treasure for the
rest of his life
yuuichi didn't even speak until the age
of seven everyone thought he was deaf
but when he started speaking everything
changed it's actually funny people
thought he couldn't speak and then he
suddenly just starts speaking fluently
with his brother he asked me Chi katsu
if he wanted to be the strongest samurai
in the nation then you'd Ichi proclaimed
that he wanted to be a samurai too and
smiled for the first time in his life
yuuichi kept asking to be trained and
finally their father's vassal who was
Michi katsu swordsmanship instructor
decided to humor the young 7 year old he
casually told him how to hold a sword
and had to stand and then told him to
come at him what happened next shocked
everyone including me yo Deecee who had
never held a sword before absolutely
destroyed the sword expert his face was
expressionless like tangelos face in his
non-self state while his older twin had
practiced and tried his hardest and had
not been able to land a single blow on
his instructor yuuichi landed four
strikes on him in the blink of an eye
and rendered the sword expert
unconscious the expert had fist sized
lumps all over his body from where you
each he hit him with a wooden sword
let's just say it's a good thing he
didn't give him a real sword then
instead of being motivated by how
awesome he was URI she felt bad he
stopped wanting to be a samurai be
of how bad hurting someone felt his twin
doe wanted to find out why or Ichi was
so strong so he questioned him and
that's when we found out that you each
he already had access to the see-through
world at seven years old something that
even our protagonist and have access to
until the age of 15 despite the fact
that you're each his twin always wanted
to master the way of the sword and be
the best he could never measure up to
your Ichi who would rather play board
games or fly kites
even though Michi katsu was talented in
his own right and tried his best his
rate of growth was as slow as a turtle
compared to your Ichi skill that gives
you a more way to just how talented your
Ichi was because of his newfound sword
skills their father was about to switch
the roles of the twins your Ichi was
about to become the heir however after
their mother died your Ichi left and so
Michi katsu got to keep his privileged
position Michi katsu developed a huge
inferiority complex especially after he
found out that not only was your Ichi
not clinging to his mother out of fear
of the world but he was actually
supporting her through her illness in
his weakest moments Michi katsu wished
that you're each she would die because
his existence defied the laws of nature
and made him feel completely inadequate
during his travels your Ichi met a girl
named Yuta they fell in love and got
married one day your Ichi left to get a
midwife for his pregnant wife
he helped an old man along the way and
by the time he got home Yuta had been
killed along with their unborn child
your DG's dream wasn't to be a swordsman
he just wanted to live a quiet life with
his family in a small house so he was
absolutely devastated when he found out
what happened he spent ten days in a
state of shock cradling their bodies
eventually a demon slayers showed up in
pursuit of a demon it was supposedly a
demon who killed your each his family so
it makes sense that he became a Demon
Slayer himself he taught the other demon
Slayers to use breathing at this point
which improved everyone's original sword
forms even further he came across his
older twin brother again when he saved
him from a demon
even though Michi katsu had a family he
joined the demon Slayers although he
couldn't learn the strongest breath the
breath of the Sun from you at Ichi he
did learn to breath of the moon arguably
the second strongest form soon after
that udg ran into moose on the
progenitor demon and the main antagonist
the series your ichi knew that he had
been born for the purpose of defeating
him as soon as he saw him he could put a
stop to the main demon that was creating
more demons and the demon population
would inevitably be weeded out this was
the ultimate test of your Ishii skill
even he sensed that even a single
scratch would kill him for the first
time ever you and Ichi felt a chill down
his spine yet he remained calm and
focused in that moment he completed the
breath of the Sun sword forms he
supposedly used the thirteenth form that
Tantra is yet to learn but is still
trying to it seems pretty clear at this
point that the dance of the fire-god was
the way tun zeros ancestors passed down
Yuri cheese breath of the Sun forms back
to the most epic battle in the series so
far Muslim was shocked when he saw you
reach his power moves ons body wasn't
regenerating this is probably because of
your teeth she's red colored blade which
represents the power of the Sun which is
the kryptonite of demons just as Jody
she was about to finish off moves on to
strongest demon ever buzan's body burst
open with incredible force it bursts
into 1,800 pieces of flesh that flew in
all directions your ichi cut more than
1500 of them which is unbelievable in
and of itself but the remaining pieces
were too small enough pieces escaped and
recombined into a lump the size of a
human head and thou us enough for moves
on to eventually regenerate it's clear
that your ichi was more skilled and
powerful than moves on the demon king of
pop had to run for his life before he
could even put a scratch on your ichi no
one there moves on would go on to have
nightmares about your ichi he completely
overpowered him busan used to always
hunt prey but now he undoubtedly was the
prey it is only after this fight that
Yuri Chi was told that his older brother
had become a demon then the unthinkable
happened because your ichi had failed to
defeat Mouzon allowed the good demon
Tamayo to escape and his brother had
become a demon he was banished from the
demon slayer core some of the members
even wanted him to commit suicide can
you imagine how irrational these guys
were being the strongest Demon Slayer
and the only chance they had at beating
moves on was right in front of them he
taught them to use breathing so they
could actually hope to defeat some
demons and yet they kicked him out and
even wanted him to kill himself
what insanity your Ichi felt that he was
born with special strength in order to
defeat moves on in
pained him that he failed to do that it
also pained him that his own brother the
closest person he had on the planet
turned into a demon later as an old man
over 80 years old your teacher ran into
kakushi bo the demon who used to be his
brother even though he had the demon
stare mark and was not supposed to make
it past 25 he did again he was the
exception to the rule you might think
that even your reach she would be slowed
down by age but he wasn't his presence
alone made Coco Chabot feel like he was
being weighed down by rocks even though
he was an old man koku she boasts on no
opening in his stance your ichi came a
Kakashi bow and sliced his neck before
Coco Chabot could even draw his sword
but the cut was not deep your ichi speed
and power were no different from when he
was in his prime Kakashi will the
strongest up her moon called his
brother's sword technique godly he was
certain that the next blow would chop
off his head however it never came Yuriy
she died standing up seemingly from old
age right to the end he was as strong as
he was in his prime not even old age
could slow him down and not even death
could bring him to his knees in truth yo
Deecee could have finished Coco she bow
right away if he wanted to but he
clearly didn't and that is why Kaku she
will survive your ichi despite his
overwhelming power couldn't bring
himself to kill the older brother who
gave him that old crappy handmade flute
when they were kids
youichi still had the flute when he
finally died with an undefeated record
so that is how strong your ichi is he
was the user of the strongest breath the
breath of the Sun he was born with a
demon slayer mark and with access to the
see-through world the first time he
picked up a sword he beat the crap out
of a swordsmanship expert he taught all
other swordsmen how did a combined
breathing with their swordsmanship he
embarrassed and traumatized moves on who
had no choice but to run for his life he
was as strong at 80 as he was in his
prime and Coco siebel the strongest
upper moon couldn't even react to his
speed and although it hasn't happened
yet it seems clear to me that the breath
of the Sun forms that he developed and
that were passed out to ton zero will
end up being the key to defeating moves
on once and for all
what's perhaps the most impressive is
that despite his unapproachable and
insane level of power your each he never
let his talent go to his head he
that he was given his talent for the
purpose of defeating moves on and as a
result he never took pride in his
strength he even downplayed it he told
KOCO Zeebo that he wasn't that great
just a mere fragment of humankind's long
long history he had no doubt that
children would be born who would go on
to surpass even his own talents although
we haven't seen any individual person
surpass and yet chances are that by
working together the current team of
demon Slayers will surpass your Ichi and
defeat Mouzon once and for all and if
things happen like that
then it's totally possible that your
Ichi will remain the strongest
individual in the entire series and that
is it for today's video thank you so
much for watching I'm glad we finally
got around to this video because your
Ichi is one of my favorite characters
and it's always a treat when I get to
talk about him if you enjoyed this video
make sure to smash that like button and
share with a friend
remember if we can get 5,000 likes then
I will get started on the next video
ASAP if you haven't be sure to subscribe
and this is crucial
hit that notification bell because you
won't know when new Demon Slayer videos
come out if you don't for more demon
Surtur content and important updates on
the new seasons falls on twitter and
instagram at anime up drawer and
remember that you can now get an early
preview of my demon sword chapter 189
review on Spotify and iTunes just check
the link in description a special thank
you goes out to our patrons on patreon
who help us survive YouTube issues and
who helped make videos like this one
possible I especially want to thank our
pro hero tier patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings ell dress fitted ala beat Anatole
cos ASCII alpha do angel Cruz and team
Sparky 65 and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans
Stephan and Radha alo la autumn Maddie
Mac 239 makoto-kun
the world stealers Tyson Kirino and the
school bus thank you all so much if you
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon comm anime
uproar and becoming a patron today for
as little as $1 if you do so you'll get
your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out
patreon.com/crashcourse
link in description if you're interested
you can also now join the YouTube
channel and support more content that
way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us you can get the
same great benefits until next time see
you space cowboy
[Music]